it was such a unique time in mixed
martial arts I'm sad because I don't
think we'll ever see it again now I know
people and Dana says this and everybody
says it's oh when magic and bird retired
it's like oh what's the NBA gonna do now
or you know when Barry Sanders retired
what's the NFL going to do now and the
UFC it's when Chuck Liddell retires what
what is the UFC going to do now I know I
I get that this is different this is
different will the UFC have more
generational talent and are they gonna
have superstars of course no doubt
there's gonna be talent that we can't
even imagine coming up in the next 10 15
years no doubt and will they be more
skilled than Conor yeah because that's
the evolution of the game no doubt I'm
not saying that we're not going to have
superstars in the UFC what I'm saying is
you're never gonna have another Conor
McGregor and that makes me sad